[Music]
happy friday creed leaders i'd like to
first thank everyone for an awesome week
back i've seen some amazing things not
only our students embodying the crete
core values but i saw rockets being made
and launching
in the steam class i saw critical
thinking and reasoning going on in the
chess class and i saw students dancing
their hearts out in the dance class
so great job during enrichment great job
this first week back keep it up and keep
embodying the crete core values
i hope you all have a wonderful week i
will see you on the yard and as always
cheerio
[Music]
what's 6 times 4
24
right one
good
can you show me now you have two things
how do you say that again
what's the next one
what's our last one
crete academy is a non-profit charter
school serving students tk through 6th
grade in south los angeles who are
experiencing homelessness and extreme
poverty
of the 187 students we are 20 special ed
we are 85 free reduced lunch meaning
living below the poverty line
and we are 30
homeless meaning students living in
shelters
motels hotels and double and tripled up
with family members
i
decided to open this school
15 years ago when i was volunteering
as a freshman in college downtown on
skid row and seeing thousands and
thousands of people living in boxes and
under tarps and
in sleeping bags
i knew then that i wanted to do
something and
i felt that the answer was a good
education and creating a space where
these unique children because they are
unique in their situations could come
and thrive
i chose to start the school in south
central because
it's known for
violence
high poverty rates and low educational
attainment rates kids who come through
those doors every day in these public
schools are lacking basic needs
and i want to see that change
my old school
all the classrooms were dirty
there was holes on the walls
and they didn't really care for us most
of the kids got in fights a lot
at my old school i was just getting
trouble just for doing a lot of
weird stuff and hanging around with the
wrong people some kids were getting all
over me and one of the staff was just
watching and and i was right in front of
her and she did nothing
this school has really helped me get
through so many tough times
they have a lot of smart people that
make smart choices and i hang out with
them now
the school is like
my dream school
good morning
[Music]
without transportation many of the kids
would not go to school
so one of the things that we provide at
our school that's critical to our
student success
and overall family support is our
transportation we transport 59 students
every day to school using two shuttle
buses that each take on two routes so
starting at 5 30.
by providing transportation we're
alleviating some of the burden on our
families and really creating more
opportunity for them to have one less
thing to worry about
pound we pounding this morning
we want breakfast when a student first
arrives in the morning at crete
they're greeted by our dean of students
who usually stands at the front gate
and
majority 90 of the students will come
and get breakfast
do good
that's all i want to know
we
first of all understand that there are
basic needs that must be met before we
can educate our kids before we put math
or science or social studies before you
we want to make sure that your mind your
body and everything else is intact so we
offer three meals a day we offer
mental health resources through our
wellness program so on-site social
workers full-time
all the things that you would need just
to be a healthy human
[Music]
i didn't have a car the first year that
crete opened up but the school made sure
my kids were
on the shuttle and they never missed
school because of that
i'm a single mom i was married for seven
years and i left due to domestic
violence
being in the shelter and being in this
space in my life where i'm currently
homeless it kind of eases you know my
thinking process like okay my kids are
safe i don't have to worry about that
now let me go and try to do this try to
do that
it takes the stress off a bit knowing
that my kids are okay
i've always wanted it to be more than
just a school and i'm proud and
excited
for where we're at but there's so much
more that i want to do
[Music]
the highlight of working here is just
always seeing kids smile
i know
every kid's story i get to know them
very deeply and intimately
i know their their family's stories and
so to
know where they're coming from and what
they've been through and to see them run
around on the playground or
you know show me their book report or
their science fair project
that's what gets me every every day
every time it's what wakes me up in the
morning is to see that
despite those circumstances despite
where you came from and what you might
be going through now
you can smile
there's
hope
[Music]
you